happy tuesday everybody
yeah shut up over there
take him out get rid of him so what's
happening what the democrats and media
once called evil is now getting a
facelift
and i'm not talking about this
no what i'm saying is what they
demonized before becomes less satanic as
they shift to a new far more evil target
and no not him either you know you guys
always assume i'm talking about him
he is evil but you remember donald trump
right
big orange guy with crazy hair funny as
hell and got more done before 9am than
biden did all day
he was hitler mussolini and uncooked
chicken all rolled into one
he was the worst thing that ever lived
and that includes whoever invented the
view
but is he really that bad now that the
despicably evil ron desantis came to
town
this monster flew illegal immigrants to
a rich paradise on private jets i
know what
so now desantis makes trump look like mr
belvedere says the new york times quote
desantis may be a more competent trump
in terms of his ability to use the
levers of state to amass power but he's
also meaner and more rigid without the
soft edges and esec eccentricity i hate
that word of the actual donald trump
wait so he's so mean that half this
country's population is moving to his
damn state
but the shift from dawn to ron was fast
i mean it was just last week that the
left was accusing trump of selling
nuclear secrets with no proof whatsoever
and despite being a billionaire so now
he's loose and cuddly
trump is no longer certifiably insane
now he's eccentric like your lovable
adorable rich uncle who wears a pirate
hat to bed
trump now has soft edges like he's a pan
of fresh baked brownies
you know what
maybe trumpy bear was right
the original trumpy bear the fearless
super plush american grizzly trumpy bear
was born june 14th flag day yeah
everybody laughed at that but now the
times finally caught on trump's so cute
you want to squeeze him and not by the
throat or his balls anymore
but you get it right the media never
really believes their political
adversaries are evil it's just how they
destroy reputations before moving on
it's like their version of a drive-by
shooting only instead of using guns and
bullets to assassinate they use words
and lies the ends justify the means even
if it tears the country apart and puts
half of cnn on unemployment
and no matter who is hitler on any given
day someone will come along to replace
him and they're counting on you having
amnesia about that just like the guy
they put in the white house
remember when trump was running you know
who suddenly became a congenial more
acceptable republican
mitt romney he became the outspoken
statesman who had the guts to criticize
trump you know because the enemy of
liberal's enemy is their friend you know
it's the only way keith olbermann can
make friends
yet remember when mid was running for
president he was a batman villain with
an mba who amassed millions by wrecking
companies he was their penguin without
the infectious laugh the media did a
huge expose on how he was accused of
attacking a classmate and cut off the
male student's hair
i didn't know he went to school with
trey gowdy
he was accused of strapping his sick dog
to the roof of his car the same thing
cat's husband does to her
but for different reasons
oh wow they feel bad about that
and of course there was this joe calling
him a slave owner
he's going to let the big banks once
again write their own rules
unchain
wall street
they're going to put you all back in
chains
you see
joe was that's even back then
when he still had some of his marbles
of course while they demonized mitt they
also said the guys that came before him
weren't as bad as they had said they
were before john mccain who they called
a warmongering racist now a centrist
thoughtful republican george w bush who
was also compared to hitler now seemed
more mainstream
hell according to the media he and
michelle obama became bffs he started a
war based on a lie but since he doesn't
like trump all the media talks about are
his paintings
so like joe's depends
what the dems call evil never really
changes
i know i didn't like it when i was
reading it
but i have to meet my quota of poop
jokes
it's just the latest republican with
serious potential to beat democrats now
it's desantis's turn because he scares
them because nothing scares the left
like competency probably because they've
never experienced it themselves
so they pull out all the standard
phrases he looks a lot like a bully and
willing to play games with people's
lives for the sake of his own ego and
advancement
yeah they lied about him fudging covet
stats starting his own fascist police
force and now kidnapping illegal
immigrants
sorry you big babies he's not a bully
when he punches back
but they did this with everyone like
wolf blitzer this has been around
forever
it's more proof that this partisan media
needs a strong laxative
and now the times sounds like us check
out this
what's more trump has the skills of a
celebrity he's funny he has stage
presence and he has a kind of natural
charisma he can persuade an audience
that he's just kidding that he doesn't
actually mean it wow that's nice
finally they describe trump the way i
describe myself
but we knew about this
years ago
i guess the media missed all of that
affability being too busy building a
cabal conjuring up russian collusion and
pushing the very fine people hopes they
were too busy trying to destroy the guy
to see that he was actually wasn't the
guy they were destroying
of course when you're no longer a threat
the dems compliment you but when you're
a republican and the times calls you
respectful and fun you know that's like
paul mccartney you know being called by
charlie manson awesome and i dig your
music
and you really screwed up if they say
you should run for president
but maybe the media and the democrats
should think twice before they decide
that you're not such a bad person after
all remember it's the same group that
lets out murderers
let's
welcome
tonight's guest
he's the first person i call when i need
advice about a rash host of dr drew
after dark it's dr drew
she puts the unity in community with
impunity host of sunny's corner on
siriusxm patriot
donnie johnson
like a pigeon if she poops on you it's
good luck fox news contributor cat
tim when he's under the weather that
just means he's ducking
my massive sidekick in the nwa world
television champion tyra
sonny how you doing uh it's going to be
my birthday tomorrow as well very good
congratulations
you know for your birthday i'll call you
hitler
oh good company good company yes because
that means you've made it apparently yes
of course yeah i'm up there with trump
and desantis now yeah what do you make
of this uh is this because they see
desantis as a bigger threat now actually
i think it's just because they're right
um desantis knows how to use the levers
of government in a way that trump did
not and this is one of the biggest thing
problems with trump when he came in it
was like he had to hit the learning
curve like he had to go in and figure
out how to do things he didn't know
where he needed people he didn't know
how to get like if we're looking at the
um immigration issue right um i hope
you're not counting on republicans to
come and save you because they're not
going to do it if we remember when trump
came in yeah who was trump fighting to
get the wall built yeah republicans they
wouldn't give him the money he had to go
and look in a defense department and
look in all these different areas trying
to scrape up the money now when desantis
if desantis were to become president you
think he's going to have to do that or
he's going to come in with a plan
knowing how to do it knowing where to
put people strategically in place to
make sure that it's done and then how to
follow through with it how to handle
media with it like if you
want to take the vitriol out of it and
just be honest about it
they're right
scientists would desantis would be way
more
able to will power than trump was and
that scares the hell out of me that's a
really good point or them to scare the
hell out of you too no it even yes
because desantis has flirtation with
government and using government force in
ways that as conservatives we should be
like okay maybe you should not be doing
that so he does have a fondness for
using government um at his will and whim
as well all right well i happen to like
what he does as long as it helps me
speaking of doctor uh before i ask you
question my left eye keeps
switching a little bit or is it direct
no it just keeps the watering and it's
like i don't know and so it doesn't duck
hot compresses on the tear duct tonight
right cause i'm wearing my contacts and
it's like it never happens and then i
sit down here and all of a sudden i'm
like i'm like the native american in
that little commercial
it makes you look charming does it make
me look sensitive yes i think the
audience finds it endearing and they
want to hug me later 100 which by the
way i'm staying at the hamptons
they're in not the area
do you agree with sonny that basically
desantis is trump but more effective
politicians he's a brilliant guy is he a
rhodes scholar isn't that his heritage i
mean the guy's a smart guy but i am i
think there's something wrong with me
because i am i don't understand why if
you help undocumented workers get to a
sanctuary city you're an evil person
i thought and by the way an island where
they have no opportunity to practice
their sanctuaries yes they he's helping
them be what they claim to be on a small
scale right i live in los angeles we
have half a million undocumented workers
we live it we we walk the walk in los
angeles we can't even tell when people
are coming in anymore but a little
island they can't handle that that's
confusing to me it is confusing to me is
it confusing to you cat
no good
i'm i never get confused yeah that is
it's a rare talent you have you always
speak with clarity
and uh very concise answers that force
the host to keep rambling
he's i didn't want to be disrespectful
no you don't have to be
answer a question well you didn't ask me
one but i can take it from here
just kick it yeah
what's interesting watching this unfold
is what's gonna happen because this has
obviously happened before as you pointed
out with demonizing republican after
republican but what happened with trump
is republicans took this principled
stance against trump where they made it
their whole identity to be like i'm a
republican but i'm not for trump
so now that we're continuing the pattern
of demonizing other republicans what's
going to happen to these people
are they going to continue to agree that
okay desantis is bad too all these other
republicans are bad too
it was just a principled stance against
trump specifically or are they so
addicted to the attention that they're
getting from people on the left that
they're going to just actually be
democrats but just call themselves
republicans i'm watching i think it's
going to be interesting to see what they
do yeah they they fell in love with the
strange new respect yeah by the way i
went through it when i said made some
criticisms of trump i had some blink 182
guy follow me and i was so excited then
i start tweeting about guns boom
unfollowed
exactly what happened in 2015
critical of trump you get all these
little fans that are like celebrities
and you could like totally get with it
and then you go like uh i wonder what
happens if i say this and they all run
away go talk about a colony on the dark
side of the moon and tom will find you
yeah oh i love tom he was the best one i
know what are you guys talking about tom
delonge blink 182 duh well you know what
i think he's on red eye once should we
end this conversation
i'm begging you too something thoughtful
round it all out for us you know what um
desantis may be the perfect republican
but i like the disrupter in chief i like
the fact that he didn't trust anyone
because most politicians are dirty when
he said drain the swamp he didn't say
the democratic swamp and he punked yeah
let's be real
and the reason why they
they privately didn't like him was and
not publicly is because he had the
transcripts he wasn't afraid of are you
questioning me well didn't you do this
and didn't you ask me for money and this
year because he didn't need any of them
he would people were behind him because
he was different because he was not a
politician the problem is we have too
many politicians in the government and
we need more people who are walking in
like we got to clean this place up right
yeah and the public that's why you liked
him yeah no it's true but i i i had to
come around to him because i was con i
was conflating his personality with his
deeds but he hadn't done the deeds yet
yeah then i liked the deeds but he
didn't get all the deeds done you do if
you put if you account for the learning
curve that's why you only got four years
yeah not gotten you didn't get eight
speaking of counting how many more curse
words we got tonight you've already used
four uh we have four left okay i'm
counting you're expecting to go off doc
i was thinking i might i might hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else